>> THIS MORNING THE FDA APPEARS
READY TO GREEN LIGHT THE FIRST
TREATMENT USING GENERAL EDITING.
IF APPROVED IT WOULD TARGET
SICKLE CELL DISEASE.
FEW TREATMENTS ARE AVAILABLE AT
THIS POINT.
SO THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE
A GAME CHANGER, CNN'S MEG
TURRELL JOINS US NOW.
YOU SPOKE TO A YOUNG PATIENT,
ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE TO HAVE
HIS GENES EDITED, SOUNDS
TERRIFYING BUT COULD BE A
TREMENDOUS BREAK THROUGH.
>> HE PUT IT THAT WAY AS WELL.
IT WILL BE SO EXCITING FOR
EVERYBODY TO GET TO HEAR FROM
HIM.
A HUGE MOMENT IN SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE.
THE GENERAL EDITING TOOL WAS
DISCOVERED A DECADE AGO, WON THE
NOBEL PRIZE IN 2020, AND SICKLE
CELL DISEASE IS NEGLECTED.
>> TWO YEARS AGO IT WAS HARD TO
IMAGINE 15-YEAR-OLD JOHNNY LUBIN
DOING THIS FOR VERY LONG.
BORN WITH SICKLE CELL DISEASE,
AN INHERITED DISORDER AFFECTING
THE RED BLOOD CELLS JOHNNY HAS
BEEN IN AND OUT OF THE HOSPITAL
HIS ENTIRE LIFE, DEALING WITH
BOUTS OF EXTREME PAIN, AND OTHER
SERIOUS COMPLICATIONS.
>> IT WAS KIND OF HARD FOR ME TO
LIKE DO THINGS LIKE HAVE FUN AND
STUFF BECAUSE I'D ALWAYS HAVE TO
BE WORRIED ABOUT IF I'D HAVE A
PAIN CRISIS OR NOT.
IT WOULD MOSTLY BE IN MY BACK,
MY LOWER BACK AND IT WOULD
ALWAYS BE LIKE A POUNDING PAIN
IN MY BACK.
SO IT HURT A LOT.
>> HOW LONG WOULD THEY LAST?
>> SOMETIMES DAYS.
>> UNTIL NOW THE ONLY HOPE FOR A
CURE FOR THE ESTIMATED 100,000
PEOPLE IN THE U.S. WITH THE
DISEASE HAS BEEN A BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANT BUT LIKE MORE THAN
80% OF PATIENTS WITH SICKLE CELL
JOHNNY COULDN'T FIND A DONOR.
>> WE WERE DESPERATE.
AT THAT POINT WE WERE NOT GOING
TO CARE WHAT'S GOING TO BE NEXT.
WE FOUND OUT WE'RE GOING TO LOSE
HIM.
>> Reporter: THEY DECIDED TO TRY
SOMETHING THAT'S ALMOST NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE.
>> I WAS WORRIED THAT I MIGHT
BE -- MIGHT GET LIKE SUPERPOWERS
OR SOMETHING.
>> Reporter: AS PART OF A
CLINICAL TRIAL JOHNNY IS NOW ONE
OF THE FIRST PEOPLE IN THE WORLD
TO HAVE HIS GENES EDITED USING
CRISPER TO TREAT HIS DISEASE.
>> I'M LIKE, WOW, THAT'S PRETTY
COOL.
>> AND SCARY.
>> AND YEAH, AND FREAKY.
>> Reporter: DO YOU FEEL LIKE A
MEDICAL PIONEER?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE A GUINEA PIG.
>> Reporter: IN SICKLE CELL, A
GENETIC MUTATION CAUSES RED
BLOOD CELLS WHICH CARRY OXYGEN
AROUND THE BODY TO BE MISSHAPEN,
LIKE CRESCENTS OR SICKLES, THEY
CAN GET STUCK IN THE BLOOD
VESSELS CAUSING SEVERE PAIN AND
DECREASED OXYGEN TO ORGANS,
CRISPER ALLOWS YOU TO MAKE A
PRECISE CUT IN DNA, IN THIS
CASE, CELLS ARE REMOVED FROM THE
BODY AND EDITED TO TURN ON
PRODUCTION OF A DIFFERENT FORM
OF THE JURY BOX GENERAL-CARRYING
PROTEIN HEMOGLOBIN.
>> IN ESSENCE IT'S A FETAL
HEMOGLOBIN INDUCTION PROCESS.
>> AND THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH?
>> FEELGTS HEMOGLOBIN WE KNOW
HAS A HIGHER OXYGEN CARRYING
CAPACITY THAN ADULT HEMOGLOBIN
OR SICKLE HEMOGLOBIN, YES, IT'S
MORE THAN GOOD ENOUGH.
>> SO FAR IT HAS BEEN GOOD
ENOUGH.
29 # OUT OF 30 PATIENTS,
INCLUDING JOHNNY MET THE TRIAL'S
GOAL, BEING FREE FROM HAVING A
PAIN CRISIS FOR AT LEAST A YEAR
AFTER TREATMENT.
>> Reporter: HOW LONG HAS IT
BEEN?
>> TWO YEARS.
>> Reporter: NOW JOHNNY AND HIS
FAMILY CELEBRATE HIS TREATMENT
DAY AS HIS SECOND BIRTHDAY.
>> OCTOBER 4th IS WHEN I GOT THE
INFUSION.
SO BASICALLY I GOT THE WHOLE NEW
LIKE DOSE OF LIKE CELLS AND
STUFF.
>> Reporter: AND WHILE JOHNNY
DIDN'T TURN INTO A SUPERHERO,
WHAT HE GOT MIGHT BE EVEN
BETTER.
>> STARTING TO TEACH HIM HOW TO
DRIVE.
ANOTHER THING TO WORRY ABOUT.
WE'RE STEPPING INTO THE REGULAR
WORRISOME OF RAISING A TEENAGER.
>> Reporter: THE CHANCE, TO BE A
REGULAR KID.
>> HE'S A CLOWN.
MY BABY'S A CLOWN.
>> YES, I AM.
YEAH.
>> YOU GUYS HEARD THERE IT'S
BEEN TWO YEARS SINCE HE'S HAD A
PAIN CRISIS.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT WILL
LAST.
YOU HAVE TO GET THE CELLS
REMOVED FROM THEIR BODY, EDITED
AND RETURNED.
THAT COMES WITH A LOT OF
COMPLICATIONS, CHEMOTHERAPY.
YOU HAVE TO STAY IN THE HOSPITAL
FOR ABOUT A MONTH.
THERE ARE RISKS, AND IT ALSO
COULD BE VERY EXPENSIVE, MAYBE
$2 MILLION PER TREATMENT.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
WIDELY IT WILL BE USED BUT IT'S
EXPECTED TO GET APPROVED TODAY
AND IT WILL BE A HUGE MEDICAL --
>> GOOD DEAL AND YOU DON'T
NEED -- THAT IS A GAME CHANGER.
WHAT A STORY, THANK YOU, MEG.